[Music]
hey Jenny
well that's some strong for lung
iContact so we're gonna bounce
they were together nine years I thought
we could handle anything until I
actually just got a drop in San
Francisco I just don't feel like I'm
ready to leave New York like that thank
you
you're beautiful come on girl we're
before-and-after pictures right now oh I
gotta kill you okay
basically I just really want you to call
your place of work and tell them you
have your period or something and they
just come over my apartment you know the
beginning of a disaster movie like right
before the girl who looks like me dies
and like right when a girl who look like
you walk outside and be like oh my God
look how crazy this guy looks this feels
like that I leave in a week and then I
turn 30 and then I die probably I need
one last epic day with my crush
[Music]
but you holding me back
I am deeply obsessed with us right now I
can't even ever say like this this is
the end of an era everything's changing
I mean we're out here take it R if you
have a girlfriend
whatever kindly leave your
heteronormative labels and a
[ __ ] box
thank you making choices you still have
that boyfriend you hate oh sorry was
just goofing around
yes this just can't be where it ends
this is destiny you are Beyonce
I love you guys for real
our best friend is out there drinking
champagne from a bottle of green juice I
just want to scoop her up and make it
all go away
wait it's the green juice mimosa its con
genius I feel better I'm gonna pick up
[Music]